et dans une laverie non quoi un
hélicoptère avec quelle femme
c'est quoi je quand je rentrais chez moi
et le le quand tu rentres chez moi
la phrase de castani quand je rentrais
chez moi en
hélicote les gens qui rentrent à vélo
c'est quand c'est quand tu dis Secret
Story exactement et donc quand tu allais
rejoindre Flavie euh non non j'étais
dans la phase de divorce là ah d'accord
donc
je rentrais chez moi en fait non mais tu
rentrais chez toi où mais en Normandie
qui t'attendait mon petit qui
m'attendait Enzo
je sais pas il y avait une femme qui
était là
genre son fils il avait 5 ans il
attendait tout seul
le réacteur qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
mais la turbine s'est arrêté parce qu'il
y a une ce qu'on appelle un un vent
ascendant ça a soufflé la turbine et là
ça s'est arrêté et là comment comment la
turbine s'arrêter quoi tu t'es prises
et en fait
toute la turbine et alors mais qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé et ben dans ces cas-là
ce qu'on fait on fait ce qu'on appelle
une autorisation c'est que le pilote moi
je j'appelle la turbine moi j'apprenais
à piloter à l'époque
et donc en fait il faut prendre de la
vitesse et et les pales vont être
entraîné avec la descente et vous vous
posez dans un champ comme ça et voilà
merci beaucoup on continue
une accident excuse-moi c'est de la télé
en panne je sauté au barrage
ton histoire elle est très bien sinon tu
fais comme d'habitude tu te tais c'est
mieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
23 je crois que c'est dans ces moments
là qu'il est le meilleur
et toi en skateboard moi j'ai jamais
pris l'avion de toute façon
non mais sans déconner il faut pas faire
tout d'un coup
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
de machine à laver non plus
compagnie vous devriez alors il va
falloir me lâcher un moment
j'ai d'autres soucis
un souci ouais moi j'ai fini en prison à
Genève non parce que en fait
[Rires]
non j'ai mangé des cuisses de poulet
genre
passeport et en gros j'étais comme une
clandestine et du coup bah ils m'ont mis
en cellule quoi
[Rires]
c'est ça ton histoire
voilà Anissa
électrique
marche toujours bien non
j'en ai déjà pris pour en cas d'urgence
je m'en suis jamais caché
bien sûr il a besoin à tout moment de
pouvoir être joignable de pouvoir aller
n'importe où et tout ça c'est pas ça
qu'il fallait dire
électrique tous les jours en plus
c'est votre copie conforme physique
qu'on voit parfois dans une grande
maison dans le sud parfois sur un énorme
bateau parfois dans un jet et
parfois mais ce mec qui vous fait
beaucoup de temps
je vais le trouver oui je pense je vais
le trouver ce gars
et si il me regarde ça va chier
je te le dis allez c'est bon là c'est
bon
il me dégoûte